laney make sure tate's not trying to
sell our customers time shares
todd keeps out at least 100 feet away
from women's wear and women in general
if possible why is nobody working the
deli
oh right dom told me that he just really
didn't feel like coming in today that i
should cover for him by telling you that
wait go back let me take that again dom
told me to tell you
that his pug elmo fell into a sinkhole
in the park just follow me
okay we need to keep the line moving we
have a lot of hungry angry people out
there
oh you can just say hangry now it's a
new word my friend's cousin made it up
i'll take rolls veggies and condiments
you start slicing the meat
slicing the meat oh sweet always wanted
to work this bad boy
not totally sure how it works just um
load the meat and then slice the meat
definitely i'm
a quick study so oh i cut myself already
oh maybe i should do marcus that looks
really bad just a nick it looks worse
than it is
kind of stings little
marcus is that your thumb
uh i don't know you don't know
why don't you check i don't want it
marcus check i don't want to see if your
thumb is on your hands
ah i need this thumb for work driving
doorknobs
we just need to put it in a cold
airtight container we'll get it to the
hospital they'll reattach it it's easy
i promise
here this should do it oh come on not
the guac it's all slimy
you're not gonna feel it this website
says we have an hour to get you and the
thumb to the hospital what happens after
an hour
um nothing it's just a good number to
shoot for why are you limping
i stubbed my toe picking up the thumb it
really stings
oh damn it okay uh act natural hey there
everything okay with you guys yeah yeah
we were just organizing these batteries
i just have a couple questions about
shift assignments oh ah
glenn i forgot to mention those
skateboarders are back oh
jeff come with me no no those girls are
big for 12 but there's two of us so
it'll be a fair fight this time
oh okay i'll be home
in five ten minutes max everyone's gonna
want to see photos of the baby
so oh amy not now
okay quick drive to the hospital
they'll reattach the where's the thumb
my thumb yes marcus your thumb there is
no other thumb
[Music]
there's just nothing like looking into
your baby's eyes
amy you want to see my baby nah now i
need everybody's help follow me please
the last time we saw the thumb it was in
a tub of guacamole but then we found
this open tub of guacamole on the floor
so it could be a different guacamole or
else it could be the same guacamole but
the thumb fell out so the thumb could
either be in a guacamole or it could be
anywhere any questions
yeah uh is it just regular guacamole no
it's uh
grapefruit ginger and lime where's
marcus
marcus is at the hospital elias took him
we have 45 minutes to get him his thumb
does the guacamole have nuts in it
what that why does this matter well i'm
allergic
in the event of a tornado you want to go
straight for the eye of it that is where
it is safest oh hi we are just
conducting a a an impromptu safety
meeting well i don't want to interrupt
uh i'm gonna need to see all
non-essential employees in the breakdown
right now the man said now so that means
now
okay i'll see you there
you